foreign
Gods walked the Earth
and tormented Mortals
Athena goddess of warfare and wisdom had
the power to destroy Humanity but chose
to protect us
Brave Young knights from across the
globe swore their allegiance to her they
learned to harness Cosmo
the power of the Stars
where fists crack to the heavens in
battles against those who wished Athen
are dead
over time
the gods retreated and became myths
but then 18 years ago Athena was reborn
as a helpless child
a night
clad in gold armor gave his life to
protect her as they crashed to Earth
and that's how I found her lying in his
arms a mortal girl with the power of a
god
since then I've been searching for a new
generation of nights
to protect Athena and the Earth
we fight
to protect ourselves
but we also fight to protect each other
there's always something bigger than you
Saya
you'll have to fight to protect that as
well
you give up
never
nice try but not to nine tap out no you
must learn when to quit never
foreign
don't
promise you won't come out I promise
[Applause]
hey catch
come on you're up next
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
and you win this fight maybe you get a
shot of me someday
Hey listen to me I'm more of that
dancing around understand you make it a
good show this time
man
fight this time it's time for
the main event introducing first the
Undisputed champion of the Octagon give
it up for Jackie the Beast
s
[Applause]
.com
and the contender who literally danced
his way to his first two fights let's
hear it for straight kids say yeah
you both know how this works
you know the rules there are none
anything goes into one of you gives up
or watch out
if you give up you're banished from the
octagon
understood
thank you
[Music]
damn it fight
hey I said no dancing
[Music]
[Applause]
why you think you can just ignore me
okay calm down big guy
[Music]
ballet's over kid
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
a
[Applause]
you give up
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
you don't know when to quit huh
yeah
I've heard that before
[Music]
and we're not done here
this ain't over
[Applause]
foreign
there's someone outside that wants to
speak with you he knows about your
search
he knows what you're looking for
you
yeah it's me
I think I found one of your Cosmo guys
I'm out here
your little show in there made some
people upset
look I'm not looking for trouble you may
not be looking but you found it